i've been a huge fan
of the two of you for the longest time
are we recording that is it starting
or are you just talking i'm not
recording at all i'm not gonna
compliment this if it's yeah he does it
he's very speaks very highly of me you i
don't know maybe he's thinking
he only does this to me on this
objectivists don't like charity so don't
compliment him he won't
he won't think it's sincere there you go
so it's
it's an incredible honor that the both
of you would show up here uh if we
let me just ask the sort of profound
philosophical question
how old do you think we would get along
if we were stuck in a desert island
together
what would life be like i thought the
original question you had that you you
sent us this question
was how long would it take for us to
murder one another or something like
there was murder
in the question if i remember i i listen
he sent us homework
right all these questions i ignored it i
i didn't spend four years at patrick
henry university to do homework
to answer your question i think it would
be very
easy for us to live together in desert
island in terms of interpersonal i know
a
lot
and i say this because i know a lot of
people who have been the show survivor
so they and i know a little bit about
the dynamics
so when you have people who are
intelligent who are going to have the
same goals
it i mean and there's space to go away
if i'm annoyed at you i don't think it
would be that hard at all
what's our goals in a desert island food
shelter survival survival survival
basically
survival and getting out of there right
you don't want to stay on the desert
island so
uh yeah i don't i don't think i think
that's true of any three
you know even semi-rational people who
uh you know who basically
share the goal that they want to survive
they want to thrive they want to get off
of the island
uh why would they be conflict yeah well
i mean there would be conflict but
and they can be conflict but they'd find
ways to deal with it i i don't have this
negative view of human beings
particularly not as individuals it's
it's when they get into mobs
and groups and collectives that ideology
can really motivate them to do horrible
things
one of the things that really drives me
crazy is how sinister an impact the book
lord the flies has had
on our culture i read in high school
it's a it's a superb book that's not
even a question but it's not accurate
we see in many situations where people
are trapped together
under difficult circumstances obviously
that book's about children
that very quickly it is not about
conflict it very quickly becomes about
cooperation
uh let's work together we all have the
same goal this is not a time to worry
about
other things it really the human beings
the animal instinct that kicks in is the
social animal
and i'm gonna shut up and go over there
and have a
like stop my feet instead of arguing
with your own because we're really
trapped in the situation and we need to
make it work well to the extent that
they're bad people bad people are dealt
with right so this is true
of all of you know how did we survive as
a species right have we survived as a
species
we've been on a desert island in a sense
as a species forever
uh tribes survived they survived by
cooperation they survived by
dealing with with bad people
civilization
is created by people cooperating and
working together and
and allowing individuals to thrive
within
within the group and when uh when bad
people arise they deal with them right
they now sometimes these groups get
captured by bad people
right and and bad ideas and probably
from day one that was going on right the
whole
the whole tribe is probably a bad idea
to begin with
but you know underneath it all
the fact is that to survive as a species
we need to
we need to think we need to to be
rational and
if if we don't have any respect for
reason then
we would all die we would die off so
that that's a hopeful message
but where does that go wrong so with
three people we might get along
we would focus on the basics of life
with similar goals uh once women are
introduced
their incessant irrationalism no no and
less of their hormones for sol look
the three of us have a desert island
would be nice but without women it
wouldn't be fun
um i'm going to edit out half the things
michael said there was broadcast
as you know i used to run the iran
institute she she was a woman last time
i looked
wait a minute and you know you know yeah
yeah
yeah when ludwig von mises or hazlitt
yes
it was mises was praising iran and some
i think it was haslam who said it to her
he said ludwig von mises said
you're the smartest man i've ever met
and ayn rand said
did he say man right no she viewed as a
compliment
right but she was she wanted to be clear
that he said oh yeah she was excited
yeah absolutely
she was prosperous i took it as her
perceiving him
as seeing her as a full equal oh i i
think that's right i think that's right
plus
plus i think the the the perception out
there
the perception and the culture of men as
being rational
you know was was a compliment because
that was that was
a firm affirming that he viewed her as a
rashford yeah because
mies is old school he's an older eastern
european guy so he would definitely have
these richard views
like his wife i read her um
autobiography margie von mises
and basically he made her his secretary
to the point where like if he's typing
something
or he had something handwritten she had
to type it out and if she made a typo he
would tear up the page you have to start
from the beginning but it's like that's
this is the role of the man this is the
role of the woman so for him to regard
her
this was kind of a breaking through
moment not that she was secretly you
know uh
misogynist
you